en las ruinas de butch a cada día trae
consigo una marea de testimonios
devastadores contra las tropas rusas
esta casa que un tiro de tanque destruyó
y en la que no queda casi nada pertenece
a irina brook no va
los rusos según asegura mataron a su
esposo olic
irina relata cómo fue asesinado
cuando mi marido no era un soldado nunca
tuvo un arma
era un hombre pacífico
los sacaron de la casa cuando estaban
zapatillas y le pidieron que se quitara
la camisa lo pusieron de rodillas y lo
mataron
sólo en la ciudad de buzzi al menos 300
cuerpos fueron enterrados en fosas
comunes durante la ocupación rusa
cerca de una semana después de la
partida de las tropas del kremlin de la
región de kiev muchos habitantes vuelven
a sus hogares
hábitat malcolm le cuesta reconocer su
ciudad por odian acá
era una zona residencial acá estamos en
la calle principal había una tienda de
comestibles una farmacia y el puesto de
policía
cómodos sin noticias de sus padres desde
hace más de un mes la joven mujer se va
rumbo a su casa familiar a las afueras
de la ciudad sus padres viven mi querida
hija
ven nos vamos pero como si ya no tenemos
carro se lo llevaron si
eran combatientes chechenos eran
brutales como panteras
a pesar de sus relatos de saqueo y
violencia rusia desmiente todo abuso en
los territorios que ocupó en ucrania